madame la Première ministre depuis 6
jours des émeutiers souvent mis par la
haine de la France on se met le chaos
dans notre pays au nom des députés de
républicains je veux dire notre soutien
assez milliers de commerçants dans les
magasins ont été payés je veux dire
notre soutien à ces milliers de Français
dont les véhicules ont été incendiés je
veux dire notre soutien aux maires qui
ont été pris pour cibles et notamment à
Vincent Jean Brun et sa famille
odieusement attaquée leur domicile
et je veux dire notre immense
reconnaissance envers les forces de
sécurité policiers gendarmes policiers
municipaux sapeurs-pompiers je pense au
caporal chef dame la cour
extraordinaire sans froid et l'honneur
de la France aujourd'hui seul une
réponse pénale rapide et exemplaire
permettra d'endiguer la violence je vous
demande donc madame la Première ministre
de publier chaque semaine l'activité de
la justice département par département
combien de personnes interpellées
combien de personnes déférées à la
justice combien de personnes condamnées
le temps des excuses le temps des sursis
le temps de l'impunité est révolu
pour les mineurs notre code pénal
prévoit c'est l'article
l227-17 que les parents défaillants
puissent être condamnés à de la prison
ou à de fortes amendes quand on laisse
un gamin de 14 ou 15 ans dehors à 2h du
matin par une nuit des meute on doit
avoir sa responsabilité engagée c'est la
loi appliquez-la
la justice doit être rapide et je vous
demande de mobiliser ce qu'il faudra de
magistrats honoraires ou de magistrats à
titre temporaire pour juger toutes ses
affaires dans les 100 jours ne pas punir
serait une injure pour nos forces de
l'ordre ne pas punir ce serait ne pas
comprendre la gravité de la menace pour
la France ce serait empêché pour demain
de reconstruire la Concorde dans notre
pays il faut un changement de câble il
doit être radical il le faut maintenant
merci monsieur le président
la parole est à madame la Première
ministre
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
président Olivier Marleix
depuis que des violences inadmissibles
ont éclaté nous avons travaillé sans
relâche au maintien de l'ordre
républicain sur tout le territoire avec
une volonté le refus de l'impunité
depuis le début des violences près de
4000 personnes ont été interpellées le
Garde des Sceaux a transmis une
circulaire de politique pénale au
parquet généraux leur demandant une
réponse rapide ferme et systématique
pour tous les auteurs et je vous
confirme monsieur le Président comme
nous l'avons évoqué hier que le garde
des sceaux demande notamment que des
sanctions pénales puissent être
prononcées par des parents qui laissent
leurs enfants de 12 ans de 13 ans de 14
ans pour traîner le soir mettre le feu à
nos mairies à nos commissariats
et au total hier soir près de 700
personnes avaient été déférées près de
800 garde à vue était en cours la
réponse pénale est au rendez-vous des
peines lourdes ont été prononcées
notamment de la prison ferme avec mandat
de dépôt d'ores et déjà 350 personnes
sont placées en détention j'ajoute que
le garde des sceaux adressera dans les
prochaines heures une circulaire sur le
traitement des infractions commises par
les mineurs d'abord pour que toutes les
atteintes même de plus faibles intensité
soit sanctionnée ensuite pour mettre les
parents en face à leur responsabilité
avec des amendes des stages de
responsabilisation parentale et en
engageant le responsabilité pour
soustraction à leurs obligations légales
et j'ajoute que nous avons demandé au
parquet un suivi tout particulier des
violences et trop nombreux à l'encontre
des élus et nous avons demandé au
procureur de prendre l'attache avec
toutes les victimes
mais monsieur le Président Marleix notre
volonté d'une réponse pénale ferme d'une
justice plus efficace plus rapide et de
réponse plus adaptées pour les mineurs
c'est tout l'engagement du gouvernement
depuis six ans avec notamment la
création en 2021 d'un code de justice
pénale des mineurs et nous veillerons à
sa pleine mise en œuvre c'est aussi le
sens du projet de loi d'orientation et
de programmation du ministère de la
Justice que vous examiniez actuellement
et je pense au recrutement de 10000
nouveaux agents d'ici 2027 pour le
ministère de la Justice je pense à la
simplification de notre procédure pénale
je pense à une meilleure indemnisation
de nos victimes je pense à l'extension
des travaux d'intérêt général et je
pense aussi bien sûr au programme de
construction de nouvelles palaces de
prison d'ici 2027 dont vous débattrer
dans les prochains jours vous voyez
monsieur le Président de marlex nous
voulons une réponse pénale à la hauteur
il ne doit y avoir aucune impunité nous
sommes mobilisés je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la Première ministre